c'était le choc de cette dernière
journée élite le racing club de france
4e recevait ce dimanche 28 avril à
versailles le stade français classé
troisième après une première période
équilibrée les locaux ont réussi à
prendre l'ascendant pour l'emporter sur
le score de 5 à 2 ça s'est plutôt bien
passé puisqu'on gagne 5,2 à deux donc
c'est plutôt un bon score on est content
du résultat
après sur la manière il ya quand même
des choses qui sont perfectibles
beaucoup d'erreurs techniques
je sais pas si c'est le terrain où notre
niveau d'implication mais beaucoup
d'erreurs techniques qui ont fait que
certaines occasions qu'ils étaient bien
mises en place n'ont pas pu aboutir
on avait à coeur de bien finir cette
saison contre une équipe sur lequel on
avait perdu
au match aller et du coup voilà on a on
a un petit peu rétabli les choses et
c'était important
avec cette victoire le racing club de
france terminent la phase régulière à la
quatrième place ils joueront en demi
finales de playoffs contre leurs voisins
de saint germain l'équipe qui a terminé
première de la division avec seulement
deux défaites au compteur
on est clairement outsiders mais on sait
jamais au match aller ici on avait fait
3 3 au retour on a perdu 5 3 mais il
s'était passé des bonnes choses je pense
qu'on peut on peut les embêter
en tout cas nous on y va pour gagner ça
c'est sûr et certain
on sait que sur un ou deux matches on
peut on peut les battre
le derby entre les deux équipes il vit
noise est programmée ce samedi 4 mai à
partir de 17 heures au camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye
[Applaudissements]